[Music]
welcome back to cbs morning's saturday
marks 20 years since the 9 11 terror
attacks and some of the victims families
are still demanding answers from the
government 15 of the 19 hijackers were
saudi nationals and many family members
believe there is a connection between
saudi leadership and the attackers last
week president biden ordered the review
and possible release of classified
documents related to 9 11. and cbs news
spoke exclusively with a retired fbi
agent who was part of a still secret
investigation into the hijacker support
network inside the u.s
and the possible role of saudi
government officials and employees
senior investigative correspondent
katherine herridge has the story
this summer brett eagleson went to
capitol hill to press the u.s government
to release secret files from the fbi's
911 case we've told the sad story for 19
years you know we've cried on camera
eagleson's father bruce worked in and
died in the south tower of the world
trade center now grief has turned to
rage
it's not about that anymore
it's about how we're angry we're pissed
off it is painful
the eaglesons and other 911 families
want details of a secret fbi
investigation codenamed operation encore
centered on the two hijackers that lived
in san diego it's a 10 year long
investigation that specifically
investigated the role that the kingdom
of saudi arabia played in supporting the
hijackers
is that the first mosque they went to in
san diego this is it right here on our
left
danny gonzalez was an fbi agent who
worked on operation encore he showed us
the neighborhood the hijackers lived in
before they crashed american airlines
flight 77 into the pentagon
this is gonzales first television
interview about the case 19
hijackers cannot
commit
3 000 mass murders
by themselves
based on what you found
do you believe there was a domestic
support network for the hijackers
obviously
no question but i can't
i can't comment on it but
you don't have to be an fbi agent with
26 years of experience to figure that
out gonzales says the two hijackers
nawafa hazmi and khalid almadar were
helped by a number of saudis including
omar al-bayoumi bayumi worked for the
saudi government in california and has
said he simply ran into the two
hijackers at a restaurant in los angeles
and encouraged them to move to san diego
and this is the building he lived in
there he helped them find an apartment
and open a bank account the two
hijackers even started flight school
nearby
can't sit on the sidelines
when i know the truth
gonzales says he's under fbi orders not
to talk about certain aspects of
operation encore because of national
security concerns as is another former
agent ken williams who wrote a memo
before 9 11 warning terrorists were
taking flight lessons in arizona both
men are now working as investigators for
the families the evidence is there i've
seen it but i can't get into specifics
because of protective order in a
statement the saudis said they had
nothing to do with this terrible crime
and they support the full
declassification of any documents under
president biden's executive order some
of the secret files must be reviewed by
saturday the 20th anniversary of the
attacks we are writing history as we
speak and it's my goal that when my
daughter goes to school when she's
taught the subject
that we get it right
for cbs mornings i'm catherine herridge
this was a very big deal right after 9
11 there were huge questions and now 20
years later it's hard to justify keeping
those documents classified for sources
and methods reasons if they remain
classified i think that needs to be
explained and tony there are still so
many questions oh and those families
want answers and the more you hear
the more mysterious it is
very upsetting